crazy crazy
hey guys I want to talk to you about
original grain uh originalgrain.com
congrats that's what you go to you go to
that link and you get to get ill as [ __ ]
look we watch look we like we watch look
that's a little [ __ ] we like the watches
like this is the burl wood and um look
they got another one here too that's a
little bit more Hefty uh and that's nice
with the the darkness this one's a
little bit light this was a little bit
Darkness depending on how you're feeling
right
badass
maybe classy kind of guy right and this
one comes with a guitar pick look it's
all made of like really nice stuff uh
and we love it here at congratulations
you know I'm I'm into watches you also
got the understate not something this
one you wear if you're British right
yeah absolutely on the side and with a
suit or something like that and um they
also re-up the glasses the sunglasses
sold out immediately with this code
originalgrain.com congrats and use code
congrats for a total of 30 off now let
me tell you something they're already
doing 20 off because of Black Friday all
right so Whoopsie Daisy you want more
off you use our code congrats and you
get that's a total of 30 off all right
uh they're running at 20 off Black
Friday deal right now but use the link
and you'll get 10 off that's 30 off
that's the highest markdown you're gonna
get for the holidays originalgrain.com
congrats and use the code congrats for a
total of 30 off and that is how you're
gonna be styling oh
the sunglasses are actually the illest
ones they're my favorites
I use them and I wear them out you know
sometimes I don't want to be too
fashionable with the sunglasses and the
thing but sometimes you want to be that
fashionable so get them all before they
sell out
[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
and three two
that's what one fire does every time and
we like that so it's all good we only
want to do things that we like in life
right but sometimes we got to do things
that we don't like in life because we're
adults and that's okay but it's just
kind of where we're at
you know an adult Nation uh and this is
adult Nation but uh yeah we are off and
running we are off and running we did a
uh I've got new dates up new dates up
they're on sale right now we have uh
well let me pull them up I should
already pulled them up but I didn't uh
but we well because so okay so here's
what we're doing actually
um we're doing uh San Diego and Portland
and you know all that Seattle that
actually sold out we're gonna add
another one huge huge theater who knew
in Seattle your boy was up there just
[ __ ] keeping them seats warm uh did
they they make chairs out there in
Seattle good let's keep them warm hey
invite crystalia cool oh yeah we'll keep
the chairs warm oh but they don't stay
warm fully why because they're standing
up during some of it uh we get it we get
it what's that all about standing up
because they can't because hey dude does
your boy keep the seats warm or hot or
right you keep them warm because the
people sit down but also keep they must
be hot because they
keep standing up you know what I'm
getting at Lakeland Florida has been
rescheduled to January 26th Jacksonville
Florida has been rescheduled to January
28th wait that can't be right right
that's not right right 26th and 28th
is that right
all right well whatever
uh I gotta text my uh my guy here
because I don't know if that's right but
that's weird that there's a day in
between
um ask Enrique right now yeah
um uh and then San Antonio Texas
February 3rd Sugarland Texas February
4th February 5th New Orleans Providence
Rhode Island New York uh Chicago but the
new ones here are Kansas City Missouri
oh wait was that no yeah that's new uh
Tulsa Oklahoma
Austin Texas March 25th Minneapolis
April 1st Columbus Ohio Cincinnati May
6th and 7th and then May 19th Boise
Idaho we're loving it crystalia.com uh
get the tickets make sure the seats
don't stay cold let's warm them up but
uh yeah well that's so obnoxious to say
that
um so go to chrisley.com and get that we
also got the merch it's great for the
holidays go to chrisley.com get your
merch keep people warm with that uh join
the cult hoodie and all that we got new
flannels coming out it's ridiculous dude
life rips
uh and make sure you show your loved one
that life rips over the holidays uh
Black Friday we're having a crazy uh
ridiculous sale I probably am saying
that a little prematurely no maybe not
right maybe not get ready for Black
Friday
um yeah so uh oh and subscribe you guys
you know we love you subscribe we've
been stuck at five bits of conspiracy
YouTube's got a conspiracy against your
boy
that's great hey hey there's a
conspiracy Chris is walking in a room at
YouTube Studios hey
oh but it's a conspiracy he's stuck at 5
96. dude what's going on he's got two it
shows why are they stuck in 596 dude
because YouTube's got a conspiracy
against some Saga but we figured it out
and that's what we do in life we figure
things out
um I was in Denver and Cheyenne uh and
that's a and that's amazing dude
uh I was in Denver and Cheyenne and it
was absolutely beautiful uh let me tell
you something dude okay first of all
Denver unbelievable 4 500 of you came
out love you all that is a crazy crazy
view from the stage I had the best seat
in the house Bellco theater killed it
all right absolutely fun had Lulu had
lenochi and uh and did the show and it
was absolutely unbelievable now let me
tell you something else too we got the
tour report up uh on the other YouTube
channel and uh we we're showing you we
talked you know we showed you about the
the
um what do you call it the Denver show
that one's up now and then we're putting
up the Cheyenne one but the uh the the
guy who came to see me was a real man
dude Donnie what's his name Donnie what
was his name the guy who does makes
these uh
tomahawks on uh Tick Tock look them up
Donnie something uh and uh he'll just be
like he's a great guy he showed up and I
was like this guy's a [ __ ] man he's
like Jason with Moab Jason Momo he's
like the real life Jason Momoa where
it's like okay I buy this guy being in a
way you're like I buy him being this
sexy because in a way he's actually more
sexy than Jason Momoa even though girls
would pretend that you know Jason Momoa
was more sexy but he's not though this
guy's like the real deal Jason Momoa
he's out there doing the Haka
performative and all this [ __ ] this dude
Donnie somebody whatever the [ __ ] came
to see me in Denver the dude's got like
millions of tick tocks followers and
he'll just be like you want me to make a
tomahawk I'll make a tomahawk and he'll
just make it where he is
he's like you want me to make a Swiss
army knife I'll just make it right now
here I got a tree let me just break some
bark off and then whittles a [ __ ]
knife out of it widows another knife out
of it and then makes a [ __ ] Swiss
army knife with those two reg with those
two wood knives
uh you know what I'm talking about he's
very big on uh on um uh uh Tick Tock but
he came to see me uh in Denver and it
was very cool that um you know
real men are out there he said it
he said it dude he said it but uh I love
Denver dude I really love Denver man we
were staying at a hotel that was awesome
I have no idea what it was called
because I'm absolutely sometimes you
know I just go right where they point
and uh this hotel was like the Maynard
or some [ __ ] wow I don't know the name
this is gonna be the episode where I
just don't know anything's names and
that's fine I don't even give a [ __ ]
dude you're just gonna be it's gonna be
this is the podcast based off feeling
you're gonna feel what I'm saying I'm
not even gonna try and I'll tell you
what I've been off the Gabapentin
all right and I'm not taking ginkgo
biloba I get it and I'm forgetting names
but forget it it doesn't matter I was in
a hotel it was really nice I was in
Denver and um
it had like a coffee shop attached to it
a bar attached to it like a [ __ ]
place where you could buy shirts and
silly putty and then I had a market that
was attached to it and uh and then the
in the market that morning they were
playing Bingo and there were two trans
women [ __ ] playing bingo from 9 A.M
to 3 P.M Bingo the whole time dude so
that's the kind of fun I have dude and
those are the kind of places that I stay
at so don't ever say I don't stay a
[ __ ] pop in places because I stay at
popping places because I was doing I was
at a place where you could get coffee
beer and silly putty and also play bingo
with some trans people and that's the
kind of pop and places that I like to
stay at dude
um and I went with David Sullivan and we
were just popping around lurking around
I got [ __ ]
you know look it's like I bought Silly
Putty for Calvin I bought three silly
putties for Calvin
I uh facetimed him I told him I got a
president he said what is it gonna be
and I said Silly Putty and he said Silly
Putty and I said Yup and he said what is
that and I told him brought it home
because he loves Play-Doh I didn't know
how hard Silly Putty is dude
Silly Putty is absolutely
um it's too hard to pull and then I
didn't have a newspaper to even use it
so like good dad but also bad dad
because I didn't know how to
I didn't know how to I did I couldn't
get you know how you put the Silly Putty
you roll it on the newspaper and then
all of a sudden it shows what's on the
newspaper
couldn't do that with regular printer
paper printed out like my [ __ ] uh
you know some some recovery [ __ ] I'm
trying to do it on that and it's not
working and it's also good to have a bad
dad you know
um
but yeah Denver was uh absolutely
amazing not too cold aided a place
called uh wow don't know the name whoa
dude what was the [ __ ] name of this
goddamn place man I need Ginkgo Franken
biloba
anyway I ate this place and they had the
ozu sandwiches dude I'm done with the
ozios okay
I'm done with the oju sandwiches I don't
you know me dude if you know me if you
know me and if you've listened to every
episode why don't I like our juice
because I want this [ __ ] to be done when
it comes out if the juice belongs on the
sandwich put the juice on the sandwich
before you bring it to me right
it's not ketchup
it's not sauce they try to act like it's
sauce dude it's like
thinner than water and so they give me
the so they're like what do you want so
I get the turkey sandwich with the
[ __ ] there I got the Thanksgiving
dinner sandwich which is like
they're trying to sandwich a fry
everything and it's fine but I say you
know what leave out the cranberry sauce
because it [ __ ] up everything in
Thanksgiving right doesn't it because
it's too sweet right what's that dessert
oh I got stuffing and turkey and also uh
potatoes and [ __ ] on my plate and you're
just gonna [ __ ] it all up with some
sweet [ __ ] dude
really
give it to me later you might as well
put a [ __ ] chocolate cake next to my
next to my dark meat
makes no sense dude
that's dessert it's not bad it just
doesn't go okay
so I got the the Thanksgiving dinner one
I dipped it in the ozu decided you know
what I'm not an ozu guy put it to the
side ate the sand sandwich honestly ate
the sandwich dry as [ __ ] and that's how
real I am dude
that's how [ __ ] real I am dude and
then they said I said can I have Mayo
instead and they said oh do you I swear
to God they said do you want cranberry
mayo and I say hey you're a cranberry
pusher man I want regular Mayo
now that's a sauce right so I like to
control how much of that substance that
belongs on my sandwich but uh as you
it's that's juice that should already be
in the shits and we all know it we all
deep down know it so I ate at this place
it was great that's three places I've
told you about don't know the names of
them that's the place that I stayed at
the other sandwich place and then the
Donny guy from Tick Tock that was a real
man
I need to pay more attention to life
I need to pay more attention to people
who come up to me and say hi I need to I
need to pay more attention to where I am
and I need to pay more attention to
where I'm going but isn't that just
everybody
isn't that just everybody right
I'm waiting in line and I'm at the
[ __ ] coffee shop at the place that I
stayed at
and this guy turns over and he says hey
man big fan I said oh thanks a lot I
really appreciate it he said I didn't
realize you look so badass Whoopsie
Daisy I'm yadded up dude
Whoopsie Daisy I'm all you added up I
didn't realize I was added up I saw a
picture of myself and I'm [ __ ] yatted
up dude right
I got one here I got one here I got a
tattoo every which way you look at me
I'm guided the [ __ ] up unless you maybe
you see me from behind I don't have any
from behind but I'm getting them
right
made me feel good
you know I don't know why every guy kind
of wants to be badass it's silly right
because we're not we watch Batman and
[ __ ] The Dark Knight whatever with uh
the good actor in it what's his name uh
Robert Pattinson got it
and uh we're like that's probably how I
would be the Batman that I would kind of
be but you wouldn't dude you just fall
down and slip and [ __ ] imagine you were
Batman you'd [ __ ] die immediately
right but you watch it and you're like
dude see I you're watching this [ __ ] and
you're like see that's the kind of
Batman I'd be I'd stick to the Shadows
right not the other Batmans didn't
really stick to the Shadows Robert
Patton said Batman he stick to the
Shadows so I get it I would kind of
stick to the Shadows dude how lost would
you get as Batman that's me
did Denver then went to Cheyenne and uh
did a trip from Denver to Cheyenne and
let me tell you something we got a
sprinter van and it was [ __ ] dope
because you can get the Sprinter vans
that all had the seats facing the same
way and then you can also get the
[ __ ] elevated version where the seats
are facing each other and you can have a
real conversation that jumps up the time
that you could have from nice from Goose
to silly goose dude this [ __ ] was
awesome when you're staring at each
other driving
dude it took it out by the way I didn't
know Cheyenne was an hour away from
Denver also Cheyenne where is it also
Cheyenne the capital of Wyoming also not
big enough to be a capital of anything
Cheyenne how many people do you have in
it 58 000 not enough how many people
were at the show one thousand that's
158th of the people knew that Chris
Delia was in town that's absolutely
insane dude I thought 1000 was a little
bit small of a show and then I realized
your boy 158th of the [ __ ] population
there he's moving up too low
played for Cheyenne and uh let me tell
you something dude
that's a black stripper name and it's
all good
right because it's the whitest place in
the world but it's a black stripper
named Cheyenne
but she just felt like she's the one
that found it hey y'all we going we
gonna post out right here get your tents
out hey y'all look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] man
it's open if this place sure is open
[ __ ]
hey y'all get the chance bring them Yaks
over here
[ __ ]
look how open this is poster right here
that's gonna be Cheyenne I'm the mayor
[ __ ]
um
so yeah and then now there's 58 000
people there and it is a place I did not
know that Cheyenne was a place
where America the American government
can fire nukes anywhere in the world
in Cheyenne Wyoming
also the reason is open space
if the bomb goes off only 58 000 people
die and you know that's a lot but it's
not you know it's not like you wouldn't
launch nukes from New York New York
Start Spreading the nukes
um
you wanna be a part of it nuke York nuke
York so [ __ ] dumb
I Wanna Wake up in a city that's
permanently asleep
[Applause]
um
um so yeah we did Cheyenne and a band of
the ride the ride was so elevated in a
in a time you know in the not elevated
it wasn't actually physically elevated
it was so elevated the time was so
elevated because we were all looking at
each other and the tour report dude we
were doing all sorts of jokes the
[ __ ] driver on the Sprint Sprinter
van we would get too loud and he would
[ __ ] put up the partition dude that's
the most disrespectful [ __ ] you can do
that's so disrespectful to be having
such a good time and then all of a
sudden you notice that partition like
the driver's just like this [ __ ] God
damn it and click some partition and the
partition goes up and he can't see us
uh but we were having a good time and
then got to Cheyenne uh you know thank
you for coming out Cheyenne I didn't
realize it was an hour away from Denver
which means that if it was an hour away
from Denver what could have happened was
all the people from Cheyenne could have
went to the Denver show even though they
wouldn't have fit because it was almost
sold out but that's still you know
um
Cheyenne dude
Jeffree Star came out to see me uh which
was very cool
tall tall drink of water
um not sure the pronouns that Jeffrey
likes to use so I'll stay off it but uh
you know
have you on the makeup he looks good she
I don't know
um he he looks good and uh Google the
pronouns you know before I get canceled
again and um but uh good good good
person there had a good time was with uh
two two women that uh I've met before
through the merch company and um he was
great dude
it was awesome I was like did you guys
have fun I always I say that to people
because I have fun the two women were
like yeah and Jeffree Star goes like
this
um
and I was like playing it close to the
chest dude
now I'm insecure want them to like me
want everyone to like me sit deeper walk
in a room and I think that people don't
like me I gotta win them over
problem with childhood
why is it
this is who I am
been delving into therapy about it
walk in the room immediately think I
gotta win people over why
doesn't matter
every room
sad
but
my bag
uh everyone's got their bag of [ __ ]
isn't it
everyone got that bag of [ __ ] in it
um
and so met Jeffree Star and Jeffree Star
my cameraman was a big fan of Jeffree
Star he's like I get pictures like okay
he kind of looks like Jeffree Star to be
honest
um and uh
yeah man oh you know what happened in
Cheyenne I met a sheriff you know what
I'm saying like that actually happened
how hilarious is that
I bet you can't go to Cheyenne without
meeting a sheriff or somebody that used
to be a sheriff well I used to be a
sheriff down there
oh yeah yeah back in uh I used to be a
sheriff down in Provo Utah oh really
yeah what made you move up here ah man
you just got got a lot got a lot down
there didn't it so I need I need some
more space I need some thinking all that
shit's code for racism I'm all good uh
we love everybody equally even racists
um
so
yeah man
crazy crazy
hey guys let's take a little break I
want to talk to you about ship station
it is the most wonderful time of the
year but listen it's also the most
hectic time of year uh everyone puts off
shopping until the last minute it's just
what happens you do it I do it all the
time and if you have an online store you
know the feeling of getting hit with a
ton of orders at once okay been there
when you're buried in orders and emails
from stress customers you'll wish you
had ship station trust me ship station
turns holiday ship storms into smooth
sailing so you can keep your customers
happy and still find time to enjoy some
eggnog uh over on my store we're ready
for anything uh including the holidays
with ship station so it's a huge help if
you have an online e-commerce store you
just you got to get ship station if
you're still using the default shipping
option to run your online store chances
are you're putting up with a lot of
unnecessary Hassle and limiting your
potential growth
uh you can manage every order from one
simple dashboard it's really great the
way they have it set up and uh they you
can print shipping shipping labels and
easily compare rates and delivery times
to optimize every shipments you keep
your customers happy and it's a really
important thing for that uh no one wants
to think too hard during the holidays
you want to be with your family and you
want to be uh uh you know
focusing on other things not work well
luckily ship station is a no-brainer
you'll save time money and stress during
the holiday rush and when you sign up
using my promo code you'll get even two
months to try it free there you go all
right so this holiday season give
yourself the gift of stress free holiday
shipping use promo code congrats today
at shipstation.com to sign up for your
free 60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code congrats
[Music]
we took David Sullivan on this trip he
talks too loud in the morning that's it
period talk softer period dude he came
over and we left
for the [ __ ] and he was just like oh he
was on the can I make a phone call I was
like sure man you know because I tell
you what it is annoying when somebody's
on the phone in the car with you it's
not a place to talk on the phone so
asking is cool but my [ __ ]
this is how his phone call goes for real
hey how's it going or oh out there
yeah all right whoa ain't that nice yeah
well I'm going to Cheyenne and uh no I
wish I was hunting Yak but I'm not but
so uh yeah y'all good there another
fence fell down
oh man you got some weather all right
well and dude it took five minutes and I
and I texted him you're too loud you
hung up the phone started laughing
because you got the text it's too loud
dude he talks to everyone and it's so
annoying because you can't talk to women
without thinking that they're gonna
they're being hit on and he'll just be
like beautiful day isn't it in an
elevator and I'm just like no don't do
it dude
how you doing today what bro what
a stranger how you doing today me what
fine what do you want dude I'm rushing
practically
don't be smiling at me if you don't know
me
but he talks too loud in the morning
people who talk too loud in the morning
I don't want to talk at all in the
morning I and by the morning I mean all
the way up until 8 P.M like I just like
let me get going for 12 hours before
anybody really bothers me if you got
something you want to say just text me
you know
I just
it's too much
I really need to be uh absolutely uh
I really need to be absolutely [ __ ] a
better person right because um
the world doesn't revolve around me but
it kind of in a way it does because I am
me right
we could be AI you guys could be AI are
you guys tricking me
I want to know really uh
really I really want to know if we're in
AI or not but it's all good
um David and I watched uh NCIS
um
two nights three nights in a row
have you ever seen NCIS man and I don't
mean the original one I don't know the
one with Mark Harmon really but I'm
talking about the New Orleans one
with Lucas whatever the [ __ ] guy's name
is from uh Friday Night Lights and Scott
Bakula Scott Bakula was in Quantum Leap
okay and he he is a cool looking dude
whatever
now in NCIS there were three times I was
watching an episode of nine of NCIS and
I actually had the thought
wait that is Scott Bakula right
because he kind of looks like a guy that
looks like Scott Bakula now
and that's what happens when you get
older a little bit and that's fine but
he did Quantum Leap that's what he was
really famous for and then all of a
sudden he's on and say dude imagine
being a guy that was had a a real career
in the in the early 90s
and now it's 2 000 and I think 15 or 14
is when it started NCIS and they and
they call you 30 years later and they're
like hey Scott Bakula want to be on the
new NCIS you gotta feel like Scott
Bakula must have just been like
uh
oh I'm the luckiest guy in the world
like how could you
not work for 30 years and then all of a
sudden just be given a franchise I mean
I know he worked and [ __ ] and I'm
obviously but like this NCIS dude they
make NCIS out of any City and it becomes
a [ __ ] Smash Hit from jump dude
NCIS
NCIS Los Angeles which by the way is
still on that started in like 2007. NCIS
is still on that started in 2003 dude
it's been on for 20 years Mark Harmon
last year was like you know what I think
I'm gonna actually not do it I'll let
the show run without me dude for after
19 years Mark I'm gonna work 400 million
dollars dude and now he's a producer on
all of them how the [ __ ] does that work
dude they're just handing money out you
know
so now I'm watching Nola NCIS Nola and
Scott Bakula dude is in it and the other
Lucas guy is in it and then two like
kind of maybe Hispanic women of course
they were like are they Hispanic and
then another dude that's a guitar lanky
white dude that looks like Neil Brennan
stretched out and then another dude
that's like a black dude in a wheelchair
and um just like a yup dude
is didn't say I stand for not come on
insane [ __ ] dude this is so regular this
show the guy's name is
Dwayne
Scott backless name is Dwayne Pride dude
and they call him
King
the most badass [ __ ] my name is Dwayne
Pride yeah but call me King so badass
dude
my name is nut hugger chick fugger but
call me scrotum that's the only more
badass [ __ ]
foreign
[Applause]
we're gonna have to stretch this case
out
and then instead of the sunglasses just
pulling his scrotum
ah Dude Looks Like looks like this chick
just such bad [ __ ] taglines looks
like this chick hey you know what
yeah I understand that we're at odds and
normally I would take this case but this
time balls are in your court
just take stretches and scrolled and
puts it over his head and flies away
on an all new scrotum
previously on scrotum laughs
[Applause]
oh no look at this he kneels down here
hold my nuts
hold my nuts I gotta kneel down and get
a closer look
previously on scrotum hold my nuts I
gotta get a closer look oh no this
killer is absolutely crazy it looks like
the balls are in his court
[Applause]
um
oh no here comes screwed him God damn it
no here he comes uh Hey scrotum how's it
going looking particularly veiny today
um so
oh no this person died in vain
[Applause]
dude so dumb
oh no this person it looks like my oh no
my cock's about to spit up
foreign that one didn't even make sense
um
yeah so we watched NCIS dude Dwayne
Pride unreal
and dude there's a whenever there's a
black guy in a wheelchair in a show I'm
just like all right dude you know I
suppression and agenda
you don't need to be pushing an agenda
that hard how about give a black guy a
roll and then also by the way I used to
like how dope would it be to be an actor
and that's your role you don't you just
get to sit the [ __ ] down all day are you
kidding me
the most annoying part as an actor is
you got to keep doing the same [ __ ] over
and over again and you gotta like walk
into a room and sit down and get up and
walk in it bro and normally the time
that sometimes the call times like 6 a.m
bro to be the guy to play a paraplegic
and just sit down all day and you don't
got to do [ __ ] people are just pushing
you places [ __ ] yeah dude
that is the killer creme de La Creme
especially on NCIS dude if you're 60 and
you get on NCIS
game over
I would so do the out put me let me be
the sixth guy
I'm way ahead of you make me be that guy
that does that every the chick with the
pink hair I'm way ahead of you
here look we found him over on
we got the CTC in the [ __ ]
um but yeah dude we watch it and let me
tell you a little bit about this NCIS
man since we're on this since we're on
the subject dude
um
he it's a New Orleans dude it's a New
Orleans
it's a show that's in New Orleans and
there he opened up a unit a branch of
the FBI and dude they like they like do
crack cases in like a [ __ ] is it
you're like you're watching it and it's
so nice looking it's like so such a
Hollywood version of what they think the
[ __ ] FBI is and like it's like are
they cracking cases in a barn it's like
a barn that like some lady on YouTube
that would decorate and there would be a
channel it would be the channel be
called like the barn and she'd be like
today at the barn Dwayne Pride wanted me
to decorate for Christmas so I did a
twit a fancy Twist on a New Orleans
[ __ ] Winter Wonderland
Here Comes scrotum now
and so uh
so the whole place is like three levels
and they got like crazy of course like
computers and [ __ ] but the best part
about it and by that I mean the worst
part and by that I mean the best part is
that dude they give Dwayne Pride there's
like there's a place called Pride's
kitchen and he cooks for everyone oh
dude it's so [ __ ]
I ran this
every end of the show he's just like
making gumbo and he's just like there
you go and dude it's so funny to think
about like uh uh what's his name Scott
Bakula like not knowing [ __ ] about
cooking at all ever you know and just
like yeah hand me the paprika we're
making andouille we're making andouille
sausage you know I mean all this New
Orleans [ __ ]
and it is so [ __ ]
dude David and I were laughing so
[ __ ] hard because we were like
because every time
Scott Bakula would be on a case and he
would be like look in pensive we would
be like gotta go get some crawfish I
gotta cook for the [ __ ] team dude and
we would just be laughing dude sitting
slaying in the same bed
look at this this was my favorite thing
Prides
kitchen it's called
uh NCIS
and this is the wiki fan base this is I
love one I love when they do so this is
the description for Pride's kitchen on
the wiki fan base right it goes like
this Pride's kitchen is a kitchen in the
NCIS
wait it went away [ __ ] is a kitchen in
the NCIS New Orleans building where the
team led by NCIS special agent Dwayne
Cassius Pride can go get some food to
eat while discussing the case
go get some food
dude take more time with the description
to go get some food to eat he's just
[ __ ] we're making crawfish with
andouille sausage man
Dwayne Cash's King Pride
is NCIS special agent in charge of NTS
New Orleans office and also the leader
of the NCS New Orleans team he's the
ex-husband of Linda Pride the current
husband of Rita devra I mean so
convoluted the father of Laurel pride
and the I mean dude you know
I love how in this because normally it's
just like when they did
um
when they did uh
when they used to do these shows it used
to just be about the case right like Law
and Order you don't have a [ __ ] clue
about their dating life you don't have a
clue like that Chris Maloney he could be
literally the gayest cop on the weekends
nobody knows
he's just cracking cases that's it he's
just walking in the rooms like so what
do we got the guy could literally be
taking Molly and [ __ ] twinks all
everywhere that's the that's the Law and
Order I want to see
so what do we got he walks in oh no I
knew him
oh [ __ ] we used to run together
previously on Law and Order
God damn it
Chris Maloney goes on the weekend pop
some Molly and can't stop [ __ ]
previously on Lord Orris so what do we
got oh I knew him splurt
with him
hello bringing Donuts previously on Law
and Order hello foreign
I've got donuts for everyone I've got
cream filled Donuts
[Music]
[Applause]
um but yeah that's the [ __ ] I want to
watch man and now it's like they try to
make a [ __ ] guy in a wheelchair and
then have the lead cook
as a personality
just leave it at the [ __ ] cases man
I'm fine with it you don't need to be
all you know
oh God these movies they're they're so
these shows they're so bad and they're
the number one shows dude
it's unreal
we're back went potty
um
oh this thing was interviewed he's a 10
but his dad is Andrew Tate
negative zero you can make negative zero
I don't know
random guy walks up hey how are you
doing how you doing I'm doing great Las
Vegas [ __ ] sucks okay dude so first
of all Billy Bob Thornton second of all
absolutely no as soon as he walks up
that this is gonna take a [ __ ] sour
turn
so here we go absolutely okay a Las
Vegas [ __ ] sucks what do you want to
know about it I mean the way the girl
laughs
I'm good on that a lot of people want to
[ __ ]
a [ __ ] will around here okay what do you
want to know about it I'm good I'm good
on that are you I am why are you filming
her
why am I I asked her to film her where
did you I did you're okay with that yeah
because these are [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
go ahead totally
go ahead all right it's all up to you we
already did it
[Laughter]
we already did it dude what a Time suck
this guy is you know like dude Lem
you're just holding up what's going to
be happening hey how's just holding his
yes I am Las Vegas [ __ ] sucks
people take people huh
you're on camera now too I'm
fantastically on camera
absolutely
a foreign dude I am fantastically on
camera
you [ __ ] don't even know not a brag
dude not a flex I played with bands you
don't even know because they're not
successful um I hate people that take
[ __ ] people are you that person no
I'm not why would you say because I want
to kill them because they are all
[ __ ] here in Las Vegas okay I'm not
from Las Vegas neither am I I travel the
world I'm a musician yeah I hate to see
people yeah bye guys thank you
I mean and then she leaves just go do
your thing the guy like
was trying to already
the way he entered
his dad is Andrew Tate the question you
know negative zero the you can make
negative zero this whole thing is so
insane
she has a shirt on that says [ __ ]
and he's got a hat on the crazy guy's
hat on that says FC UK
guy walks up how you doing I'm doing
great Las Vegas [ __ ] sucks
foreign
I'm doing great Las Vegas [ __ ] sucks
how much is that guy's wife been looking
him for him for 30 years
know about it
I mean does it you're not included guy
I'm good on that a lot of people want to
[ __ ] take people around here dude
this guy is like honestly I I'll tell
you right now I know a guy like this
that isn't like this yet that's going to
be like this in 20 years what do you
want to know about it I'm good I'm good
on that are you I am how are you filming
her
dude this guy thinks he's being such a
bad he thinks he's Liam recently taken
and he's wearing a [ __ ] birds of
California shirt and a and maroon
stained shorts
with a bag of what though I don't know
where the [ __ ] is in there is absolutely
insane
and his leg is bleeding wow his leg is
bleeding dude well I asked her to film
her where did you I did I mean wow God
it's just so much sadness out there
mental health time
to set
but you know what it's like people say
you gotta give people a pass when they
have mental health but then also if you
really think about it definitely Nazis
were suffering from mental health and
look what they uh [ __ ] accomplished
so
you know maybe also take it seriously
even if they're saying [ __ ]
um yeah so
I uh I did my show speaking of actually
speaking of Nazis let me go to this KFC
apologizes after German Crystal knocked
promotion um it's fried chicken
let me look up Crystal knocked I know
it's bad but I'm not I'm not too clear
on what it is uh
uh Crystal knocked oh wow okay the first
thing that came up was crystal knocked
2022 so that's probably going to be
something very bad
um Crystal knocked if for those of you
that don't know what it is
on November 9th 10th 1938 Nazi leaders
Unleashed a series of
pogroms against the Jewish population in
Germany and recently Incorporated
territories this event came to be called
Crystal knocked the night of broken
glass because of the shattered glass
that littered the streets after the
vandalism and destruction of Jewish
owned businesses synagogues and homes so
KFC was like
let's make chicken
KFC always apologized after sending a
promotional message to customers in
Germany urging them to commemorate
Crystal knocked with cheesy chicken
this is the most stay in your lane
[ __ ] thing of all time
the nazi-led series of attacks country
38 1938 left more than 90 people dead
and destroyed jewish-owned businesses
and places of worship it is widely seen
as the beginning of the Holocaust
message heavily crucified insensitivity
was later blade on it an error in our
system
I mean so over
the fast food chain said an app alert on
Wednesday saying it's Memorial Day for
Crystal knock treat yourself with a more
tender cheese on your crispy chicken now
at KCF
at KF cheese
around an hour later another message was
sent with an apology according
what was the error
what was the someone hit the Nazi button
what was there uh sorry dude it's
hilarious if you first of all it's
hilarious if you have the KFC app
okay second it's hilarious that there's
a KFC app
third it's hilarious that they alert you
into anything
fourth they alerted you to kristallnacht
by trying to sell cheesy chicken
and five or six whatever we're on they
apologize an hour later oops sorry
celebrate kristallnacht with cheesy
chicken and you're like that's kind of
weird and then sorry
hey sorry at KFC
um
oh God I I love [ __ ] like this man the
world's fake
the fast food chain said the automated
push notification was linked to
calendars that include National
observances
all right fair enough but then where's
the boxing day one you know
where's the Kwanzaa one did they give
you one for that
hey today we celebrate the K the [ __ ]
KKK with our KKK karispy chicken
coming out and take a bite of our
crispy chicken kkkfc
um
unreal I was at the uh I did a show at
the Hollywood improv last night and it
was really sweet man I went to dinner
with my uh my business manager and this
investment dude that I I I I I work with
um good guys really good guys had a
great time we went to this place called
Laurel Hardware and then it was way too
sceny dude you know the place is way too
sceny when there's like
you know
like if there was like a group of way
too fashionable people outside of it
and
um
and it was seen sounded like it was loud
we were gonna go to uh Laurel Hardware
and then my buddy was like nah we're
gonna actually this is what you don't
want because I said I didn't want it to
be sceny and then we went over to
um what do you call it uh
I went over to uh we went over to
Delilah which is across the street
Delilah is good food man we got the
Fried Chicken it wasn't Crystal knocked
but we got the Fried Chicken anyway we
got the fried chicken sandwiches and
they were really [ __ ] good Delilah is
pretty pretty cool uh I maybe have been
there once before
um and then I went and we took I took
them to my show we did I did a show and
I I as I was getting my car out of the
valet this dude comes up to me and he
says hey man I can't believe I'm seeing
you but I was supposed to go to your
show tonight at the Melrose improv in
Hollywood and I got it for the wrong
date and he he looked and he showed me
the ticket and it said for a different
date than what my actual show was on
which was this night and he said and
it's just so weird I just started
walking from the Improv and now I'm
right here and I'm staring at you and
it's so crazy because it's better that I
get to see you and meet you than it is
to even go to your show I said oh well
let's take take a picture with me he
said oh man awesome I took a picture
with him and he sent it to his buddy and
then he I was like dude I I was like are
you go do you have anybody that you were
gonna go with he was like I was supposed
to go with my buddy but he bailed on me
and I was like well why don't you just
go I I can get you in I mean I know it's
sold out obviously because your boy is
your boy but you can I'll put you on the
list he was like really and I said yeah
and I [ __ ] got him a ticket and he's
and I'm then I get on stage and I'm on
stage I see I look over to the right
he's there sitting alone and it was
really [ __ ] sweet dude and it made me
feel really good and I'm glad I ran into
him he made a [ __ ] mistake he wasn't
going to be in town he's from Las Vegas
Las Vegas [ __ ] sucks I hate when
people take people but um
yay went to Las Vegas
and uh
or he was in Las Vegas and then he was
at my show and serendipitous
Lee he found he ran into me and then
there we go he was at my show and it
felt so nice for the guy dude I was
really happy about it so there and you
know what that's the end of the
[ __ ] story dude
too low
um but it was beautiful and then after
my show this woman comes up to me and
just says hi Chris and I say hi and she
just broke down in tears
and I said no no why are you crying and
she was like she actually said we're
we're in the middle of the doorway and I
was like that's okay you don't have to
cry she was like no but I think we're in
the way and she's like oh come outside
so we went outside and she was like
you've you've you've helped me with my
OCD I have OCD and it's really bad and
I'm terrified of flying and and and I
was like uh I'm sorry you're there but
I'm happy to be there for you I'm glad
you listen to the podcast and my comedy
and [ __ ] and then she was like uh but
bawling and I was like let's take a
picture we took a picture and then she
says I have something for you and she
hands me a Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf uh
gift card and it was the sweetest
[ __ ] thing man it was so sweet she
was like it's weird like I know you but
I I don't really know you but I know you
like coffee bean and I wanted to do
something for you so here you go dude
and it touched my heart man
it just touched my heart
and I you know my I talk about OCD a lot
here on this podcast or a bunch you know
I have OCD and uh you know it's always a
little bit weird talking about it
because I feel like I'm exposing myself
to you
that's unsexual but uh yeah I just uh uh
fight the good fight man OCD is a real
tough thing and um my heart goes out to
those people who have it and anyone
dealing with mental health
um I really uh I have I don't know what
but I've turned a corner and I really
like and I enjoy meeting fans you know
sometimes it's annoying right but
somebody flew in from Egypt to go to a
show and somebody was in from South uh
Korea I was like Jesus Christ I guess
I'm gonna have to do a show out there in
[ __ ] Cambodia or whatever the [ __ ] it
is
um but yeah I don't know dude that was
the end of the episode for YouTube if
you want the raw uncut version the you
the uh the one the version that's not on
YouTube going over to our patreon at
Chris uh patreon.com Chris Dalia and you
can listen to the rest of the episode of
Raw and Uncut no ads and you can also
um
listen to all the extra episodes that
have been in the past I think there's
about 18 of them now maybe even 19. I
don't know but go on over uh Chris uh
patreon.com
and thanks for watching
[Music]